okay can you hear
me uh my name is Remy and I want to show
you some
code just one other code I claimed here
this is the second most optimized code
in computer science uh let's see what it
is so we're looking for all the two post
x z such that there's exist some Y where
X Y is an e and Y Z
SNR um You probably recognize that this
is the relational joint that Shia who
just talk talked to us about right so
why do we care so much about this it's
really powerful because it lets us uh
combine data from different sources it
also lets us compose programs uh from
different
components it's also really efficient uh
given this one single line line of code
the alizer can automatically paralyze it
make it work over distributed stor
storage uh make it default tolerance and
then make over work over streaming data
uh it's also beautiful right so if you
look at any uh talks talk videos in our
program you see some really deep and
elegant connection between database
Theory uh and uh fing complexity uh
traditional AI uh and also uh
probability inference so I encourage you
to check those out if we change this uh
these two operat a little bit we replace
this with multiply and repl that with
plus uh I hope you recognize this
problem here uh anyone realize what is
is m m right so this is number one most
optimized program in computer science
right uh so as we all know if you care
about physics if you care about science
if you care about uh machine learning
you're going to need this thing uh and
then in our work we actually look at the
sparse sparse case of this expression
which works over sparse tensors and
matrices uh and then we were able to
Port over some of the database
optimization techniques to optimize
sparse linear algebra so let's see what
else we can do to inspection so we can
replace you know these two operators
with any saming uh times and plus uh and
then we'll see in a bit uh what what
computation we can express to make it
even more interesting let's introduce
some recursion right so here we have the
same expression we have a base case and
then we introduce R also on the left
hand side to make it recursive so we
have here uh is just you know the base
case we say that is e is in R and in the
recursive case we uh join together in R
uh to put in in a s so to be a little
concrete if we work in the bullan saring
this tells us uh if we think of e as a
graph which two vertices are reachable
in the graph so we are Computing the
transit closure of the agation with this
very simple uh clean logical definition
that you can actually run uh in this
systems called deog including the one
system by
relation and then if we replace the uh
submarine operators with the tropical
submarine we see that still one on the
program you can find the op shortage
path uh in the uh in the program and
then through uh if you put it through
our Optimizer we're actually able to
automatically find do for algorithm to
run this
efficiently uh and then maybe this too
simple of algorithm so let's go to uh
one of the most complex ones we can
handle right so here is a pretty recent
algorithm by uh Brandis to compute the n
network centrality of a graph and they
were able to specify the algorithm in
just 10 lines of code uh and then alizer
automatically discovers this uh this
pretty recent algorithm which performs
thousands of times faster than the naive
computation uh and that's all I got
thank
you
any any
questions yeah can you say a little bit
about how the optimizer
Works yes uh so the reason we use cmer
Rings is that we are able to use the
associativity and commutativity of the
of these uh these Al algebraic
properties as rewriting rules so you
basically give us a program and then we
we use these algebra properties to
rewrite the program into a different
form uh and then sometimes um uh that
would leverage things like sparsity to
make things faster so that
suggest thanks a
[Applause]
lot